all right so we'll start from from code
q9 right
like he's gonna resist
here I'm trying that he resists
okay what is messing you up
you going around his Center he's gonna
be really fast getting back
you have to make him have to gain his
balance he has to counter the kazushi
okay if I if I go like this I go around
to the center there's no account he
doesn't have to counter he's he's still
going to get him
so I'll have to counter this kissing and
then he has to come at me okay
this is the second thing that's
perplexing you is you're bracing
on this throw
if you brace on the throw
you have to wait for him to unpin you
before you can move that gives him time
so you're not bracing on the throw so
that you can move freely you have to
ground Vector on the on the throw so
that you can move free
room in the center and I can move
Center
oh ground vector
move freely
okay let's try
it there you can't just do it
technically okay you're like doing it
technically there is a mind component to
it so my my mind is uh calm
calm and observant and receptive okay so
boom I'm doing everything
I'm also feeling for his grip
right let's say his grip is really tight
I can tell
you see yeah that's not gonna work so I
might have to do an escape TJ now
some of you guys are getting trapped or
you're like all living that volume down
Moon box
[Music]
and he's coming at me so he doesn't come
at me I'm just gonna attack right here
do you understand okay do you understand
so you have to make sure that you're
coming at me okay
so as soon as you feel that's it
I'm calm oh
here
first one
second one
hello
Center
right into it
you're going to drop your elbow so his
butt sits down don't pull them back
his Energy's going forward
slap his butt down
first squeeze
then
okay yeah
so you have this coaching
right you have that coffee nugget yeah
[Music]
right
now I'm gonna use that principle
Paul comes in boom
I I cannot use
this it's all postured he's stronger
than me I'm not gonna do it I'm not
resist I cannot get that
but I can use
his energy
see I take a right on his butt okay now
it's 9 out of ten people I'm I'm already
choking them on the way down do you get
it so by the time his butt hits he's
passed out okay if he starts fidgeting
with my assets when I'm gonna come in
and protect my hands and then get it
notice how
how that leg is there
so if he tries to shove me backwards
that leg is there it'll be over by that
time
so you can go slow
but
you'll have to keep the kazushi
you see that boom
okay let's go
all right so we'll do it from uh uh
cleansing either the clinch right or the
clinching attempt so hope then he comes
in again there it is right there
okay so here clinching attempt comes in
okay let's go okay let's go back a
little bit so he's he's trying to do the
Clincher I'm always going to start to
fight Spider-Man I'm not gonna stand
here and
do this stuff
or do this and I'm trying to Evie no
he's he's bigger than me so I'm always
going to yield and start to fight
spiraling so these clinches
well here's my guard do you think
because he's mothering my strikes
but I'll be on the inside of his elbows
there's his elbows right there
so we slow it down we work cool if you
not get started
might he
resistant the Z has used his momentum
against him then just sit his butt down
boom boom
I'm going back to the cookie nugget
whichever hand comes up on the head
you go the other way
but keep your hand up
don't reach out for him
no
my hand is up I let him reach for me
he's trying to clench me that's when I
go
you see yeah
okay
knife edge inside the elbows
okay so while he's in in his position
right this is not all not only when when
I'm going to throw him
so his energy is going forward that's
not only when I'm gonna drop him
but that is when the choke starts so
that he doesn't have his
um supports his post ability on the
ground okay so I'll go I'll go slow but
you'll see it's already choking so by
the time he's on the ground that's what
I said like it it'll be over by that
time okay so I'll do it
a little slower
as we go
you see so I'm I'm using his way some of
you are like usually in your way to take
him down
but now you can't hang
okay
so I'm not using his way I'm losing his
forward energy to take him down I'm not
using my weight so I'm not using my
weight to take him down I'm using his
forward energy to take him down so as he
goes forward it's hanging it's hanging
him as he's starting to fall
excuse me it's hanging him too you don't
want to go Andrew you you'll keep using
your weight
leave him up you can't hang him you're
gonna it's all gonna be muscle
and then the other thing I would say
here
is
tear my form is okay because let's just
say it's going south and he starts
pulling that arm off of me and I'm here
like this he'll pull it and he'll get an
arm break on this arm over here well
don't do it
he'll definitely get out but this is
anchoring can you see so he pulls it and
he's gone I'm hanging him I'm hanging
him it's too late okay so that forearm
is acting as a resistance to his pulling
and then the last point
again
it's it's his energy
uh I don't want it to come backwards
into me so that he accelerates me back
backwards okay so I don't want to walk
him back because he'll accelerate
scrambling again
hence you want to do it while he's gone
forward
but
my my ground vectoring is stopping him
just like he's pushing here he can't
push me he's never he's never going to
push me
so the same thing here as we're going
back down he drives by he's not going to
drive me back he's not going to drive me
back he's not going to drive me back
[Music]
you see it's still ground Factory okay
um and like I said if for some reason
maybe you're on
you got brand new leather soles and
you're on some slick carpet okay and you
can tell you're going backwards that's
where you dish him because you don't
want a graph like that guys
okay all right
try to bring that